let's talk about gavin newsom real quick
oh yeah we have this from the hill
newsome joins trump's truth social to
call out republican lies
this is actually quite uh quite amazing
he says quote i just joined tr trump's
truth social going to be on there
calling out republican lies this could
get interesting my first post breaking
down america's red state murder problem
he said adding a link to his truth
social post yeah i know like urban
centers are all in you know blue cities
but um here's the funny thing
twitter bans their way to irrelevance
and now prominent uh prominent democrats
like i better go over here
to engage in this conversation
this is his second self own in as many
months i think he tried to poke fun at
um
why is it a cell phone because he's
basically admitting that he doesn't
support free speech on the one hand on
the twitter platform but does support it
and wants to flock to it on another
platform this is the same guy who
tweeted out
a mocking photo of desantis he was
reading books that desantis was banning
not realizing that the same dude in
california are banning books he doesn't
understand the cell phone when it
happens but thank goodness that he he
gives it to the public could it be
that the democrats
the the the leftists of big tech who
have banned these conservatives have
created a boring platform and now
democrats are going to want to go to
truth social what if it turns out that
twitter ends up dying elon buys it then
everyone's like well but twitter's so
last election
truth social is funny because trump's on
there and we all want to know about it
these journalists are going to have to
report on what trump truths is that what
it's called he's true
he's true so when trump when trump
truths
that's an amazing thing to say by the
way
journalists have to have accounts to see
what he's saying
forcing them to sign up and be on the
platform then what's the point of being
on twitter it's not it's gonna be it's
not gonna be newsworthy anymore the
people are gonna be on truth and trump's
gonna control it now you're on his
platform baby is that where we're going
it's going to be interesting to see if
trump censors uh gavin he's not going to
sense no
it would be it would be stupid for him
to do it but it wouldn't surprise me you
know what might happen gavin might get
his butt handed to him on truth and he
might actually say holy crap california
is not doing well in a great many
respects he might actually see the truth
on truth
wouldn't that be ironic this warrants
like some kind of sketch where gavin's
like i'm joining truth a week later he's
wearing a maga hat
he's i've seen the light you hear the
story about these moderate content
moderators and feds that when they go on
facebook and they join these groups they
end up getting radicalized and they're
you know i they call it radicalization
in the media but i'm like perhaps the
moderator is seeing like real news
stories that normally get removed and
they're not getting the filtered
narrative anymore and so they're going
like whoa well that's the whole point of
strategic empathy used to be you taught
in the state department military you
have strategic empathy for your enemy or
adversary but the question is why don't
we teach it anymore in the u.s state
department well what happens if your
strategic empathy leads you to be more
pathetic to that perspective and all of
a sudden you can't hate say russia or
putin or somebody else around the world
you can't despise them anymore because
you've learned to understand them and so
we've we've uh taught teaching it so
that people don't do it and what big
tech is trying to do is to not even let
you have access to it because once you
do people end up opening their mind to
different perspectives especially over
the last i mean basically you look at
every alex jones conspiracy theory from
five years ago and we've lived them over
the last five years in some form and so
all of a sudden people re uh uh perceive
alex jones in a whole different light
they can't afford that to occur that's
why they need people to never listen or
hear that information the first place
this censorship is about controlling the
audience not just the listener and i
think that's what we would forget about
the first amendment the first
amendment's not only the right to speak
it's the right to listen it's the right
to hear
testify that's actually
quite beautiful robert
it's actually crazy to think that
silicon valley executives could
determine what you could listen to what
you could uh be able to think about and
that level of power is god-like
let me ask you a question have you ever
watched a video that you thought was
like the best video ever and you want to
show your friends and then you're like
watch this watch if you you play it and
as you're sitting there they're not
reacting to it and you're like they
don't like it this is really awkward and
like they're not laughing at it
zuckerberg or any one of these tech
people could could it's not just about
negative it's not it's not about
censorship they could be like this
message should be put out they could go
in and force you to watch these things
no absolutely you know the thing that
kills me though
is i've been in this space for like 20
years and i remember these guys they're
all talking about the free and open
internet we love like free speech
matters and then all of a sudden in five
years what happened to these people
like it was was this just [ __ ] for
the last 20 years like how did they just
flip like that like i i sit and i sit in
this chair now and i'm like i can't
[ __ ] flip like that i can't swear i
don't know what it is
we try not to but look when when when
the when the lizard people came down and
implanted the brain slugs and took over
their minds i'm kidding by the way but
uh
that's gonna be in usa today tomorrow
well i had this discussion with
twitter's lawyers in 2016. because i was
suing for charles johnson who has you
know eclectic history but the against
twitter and twitter at that point at
least jack dorsey was serious about the
very same rules that rumble's talking
about now putting in those kind of rules
codify the existing law that will
protect that you know there's no first
amendment protection for stalking or
defamation or doxxing of these things
anyway that they were claiming they were
worried about and it ultimately didn't
go through and the impression i got is
the investors that invested i don't
think dorsey was fully gung-ho behind
all the censorship that took place
you're seeing that in his alignment with
elon musk now but i think for the most
part they went a little trump
trump winning wasn't supposed to happen
you have the authority
like i can't
there's no excuse and i look at them and
i'm like
they all capitulated to the pressure of
investors george soros publicly said he
was going to go after uh facebook i mean
this is a guy who helped sink the
british crown saudi arabia and also you
got to understand elon musk buying
twitter has started uh people like with
the with the clintons the obamas and and
uh bill gates throwing secret money into
shadowy funds attacking twitter trying
to get advertisers off of the platform
and coordinated attacks particularly
when the takeover is going to be
complete so there's a lot of power a lot
of money behind the scenes that are
influencing uh a lot of things that we
don't know about but but again
as you said i i i kind of agree with you
more it's it's on him but he was facing
a lot of pressure we have that every day
yep right now like i'm not going to
capitulate to that yeah i i'm more
empathetic i don't think they
capitulated i think they genuinely think
they are suppressing freedom of speech
to guarantee freedom of speech i think
they've actually convinced themselves
they need to do this in order to create
a platform that's welcoming for
everybody if you have an open debate
about trans
sports activities it's going to make
people feel unsafe to talk and they need
to limit the freedom of speech in order
to promote the freedom of speech it's
it's orwellian uh
lunacy but i believe they actually
believe it well it's it's
this is
i think i think one way to put it is
they're anti-meritocratic
and the conversations that rise to the
top that dominate or the information
that does
they don't want to
so if you say something like two plus
two equals four
it's not so much that they're
they're threatened by it because they
don't like it it's not that it's not the
idea they want they don't want an
individual to rise up through merit and
hard work and good arguments they want
to control those arguments they want to
control those narratives
so they need to eliminate that that
element of it yeah the problem is
there's way too many control freaks
there's way too many bill gates types
just so control control control you know
you dig into gates what's go by politico
2017 politico's european union uh
organization who says bill gates is
getting way too much power and influence
in the public health world these are
public health whistleblowers then they
disown their own peace by 2020 when alex
jones and others are saying bill gates's
agenda is going to be reflected in a lot
of public health agendas around the
world and we actually saw it happen we
saw event 201 become a reality around
the globe
um it's because they ultimately there's
too many control freaks and positions of
power in big tech and stock and now we
have something called the bill chill
where a lot of scientists are afraid to
even criticize anything associated with
bill gates or his money or his
investments whether it's fake meat or
medical procedures or anything that is
tied into his money bill gates is known
to have a reputation for punishing
people cutting funding getting rid of
money because his money's in all of the
medical community almost and and
punishing people for daring to release
data or information that goes against
his monetary interest it's called the
bill chill and it should terrify
everyone especially looking at our
modern day scientific community and how
easily could be manipulated by by the
millions of dollars that he puts into it
we're living in an age of uh basically
real-life bond villains and uh james
bond is alex jones
i'm trying to think of a good a good
rhyme with fouchy because the bill gates
method is exactly the fouchy method it's
when you control the purse strings of
the funding you'll get you'll you'll get
people to say what you want uh and then
the doctors that speak out or whoever
else speaks out
they'll get the this is why they're
pushing the fake me the corporate media
saying this is great this is awesome for
the environment well well that that that
that's looking like it's not the truth
it's nutritious well that's also new
data coming out so it's not like meat
exactly
and and again it's it's about just
trying to reprogram people to to accuse
to go along with eating soy and bugs and
all this other stuff that is not good
for you and people need to really
understand the influence that these
people have because when the information
comes out highlighting how these people
were lying manipulating and marketing
their products through science uh when
people call it out we get censored we
get attacked and then we get down ranked
in the algorithm d monetized and shut
off from the internet they're trying to
plug everybody into the matrix man
they can't have you handing out red
pills luke
yeah pretty much yeah it's been it's
been an uphill battle for a very long
time i mean you've been there with me uh
you took it you were the first to get
demonetized
yeah yeah one of the first channels it
was it wasn't even yellow they just took
off the money sign and i was like what
is this does anyone know what's
happening here no one knew yellow didn't
so before youtube had demonetization
right so if phil's not familiar you go
on youtube and in in the studio you
upload a video and there will be a green
dollar sign that means you've got ads if
it turns yellow it means you're limited
if it turns red with a line through it
the ads have been removed or can be
grayed out and say not eligible
before that any of that it was just a
green dollar sign saying it hasn't been
turned on
i'm sitting and talking to luke and he's
like what happened he looks at his video
and the dollar sign is gone and then he
has to go back in the video and turn it
on again and it comes back because
youtube didn't actually actually have a
plan for demonetization
so and then there was absolutely they
manually did it and there was options to
not even turn the money on
it was and they got rid of that option i
was like wait what's going on here i i
made public posts about this i made
videos about this i was like is this
happening to anyone else no and this was
before the major wave of them just
attacking people's livelihoods and
trying to also this is another
underhanded thing that they're doing
because they're also incentivizing
people to talk about particular issues
or have stances on particular issues
because they know it's going to give
them money they know they're going to be
able to monetize content if they say
this they know if they they counter it
they're going to lose money i just want
to point out that
from 10 years ago when they were trying
to
destroy your youtube channel because you
were you were going up to prominent
individuals and questioning them and
challenging them ben bernanke several
times you know he was he chair of the
federal reserve yep
a whole bunch of them so 10 years later
your face is on a time square billboard
i know
so the way i see it is we keep we keep
pushing back we keep challenging these
things and we're going to keep winning
well the the the other thing is you know
that by the subjects that they're
targeting whatever they whatever they
tinker with the algorithm is the
you know unwelcome discussion of the day
you know that it's not what they're
telling you uh the january 6 committee
hearings i've been live streaming it in
as much as it's been tedious and soul
crushing
uh the first one i put up
got demonetized you know as i'm five
minutes into the stream demonetized fine
i ask for remonetization it gets
manually uh approved for monetization
good i'm all happy i checked just for
the fluke of it a day later it's been
age restricted and
and
i was like guys you just approved it
yesterday but you know that this is were
you debunking
i was commentating but it got manually
approved after it got it got remonetized
after manual approval and i was like you
can't a day later after you said it was
good after manual review say it's not
good and you just know it's a subject
they want to control the narrative on
and that's their way of doing it soft
censorship they say don't talk about it
because you won't get paid for it oh by
the way you're not getting paid for it
so we're not gonna we're not gonna
promote it because we're not making
money on it and that's how they just
control the narrative through the soft
indirect and hard censorship of
demonetization yep and and and that's
what i was mentioning earlier uh
mentioning earlier about how
you know they'll censor 60 of the right
and only a small portion of the left
that it creates a lopsided narrative
where the left gets to say more than the
right does hoping that it skews politics
in that direction with demonetization
left-wing channels get demonetized less
than the right does many many people on
the right have been banned and booted
sometimes not even warning
restricting the access to funding
does the same thing you make sure
certain ideas can't survive but i will
tell you this they are losing
they're losing man that's why i
mentioned you know luke they tried
destroying his youtube channel and now
he's on one of the biggest billboards in
times square because we're and that's
why i wanted to do it to make that
statement to make that point because we
can yeah because they're not going to
win this one well when your free speech
is going to win is so desperate that you
have to gatekeep to protect amber hurd
you know you're in it you're just
discrediting yourself on a constant
continuous basis uh though it won't be
long before youtube comes after lawtube
because they showed independent
information independently streaming
trials people like nick rakeda people
like emily baker all that people like
legal bites that whole crowd that okay
people can come to their own independent
conclusions they don't have to rely on
the washington post interpretation of
events and it turns out the washington
post put a liar and a defamer
on their front opinion pages for a fake
story that and to continue to make amber
heard the symbol of me too if you wanted
to destroy me too that's what you would
try to do and yet they continue to do so
and instead they're going to try to
probably go after demonetization that's
their theory their theory is oh these
people must have taken johnny depp's
side not because the facts were
overwhelmingly in his side but because
they got to see the taylor lorenz story
yeah yeah i mean infamous libeler nobody
live i mean she libeled uh ariana jacobs
area influences oh a back of ways and
she's not political at all she's just
somebody that was an economic competitor
to certain key people in hollywood who
were aligned with taylor lorenz and just
just one thing david mamet had a great
expression or a great saying every fear
hides a wish robert in that fear might
be a wish come after law tube i don't
think they will
because
they might they might get sued if they
try to mess you know try to try to
we're going after 50 lawyers all at once
that's what happens
and and there's a community there but
like they taylor lorenz washington posts
uh it was washington post right when
after alita legal bites emily d baker
and and their criticism they're making
money
right hey you know what they're making
money and they're making lots of it
probably more than you because of their
merit she called them radicalized for
commenting on a pop culture civil court
case that is insane women they're two
women who took the side of johnny depp
and they're they're calling them
misogynist johnny depp who threatened
the president it's not like he's
associated with the right i mean this is
a guy that's been part of the strong
left but it's just amber heard story was
clearly fake from day one i mean it was
clear the british courts were
intimidated by the court of public
opinion that's why they issued that
ruling anybody who followed that case
knew that ruling made no sense uh in
what is the whole i mean that was a
fairfax jury that was a liberal
democratic right down the street exactly
no it was like the idea that this one
had anything to do with politics but it
shows their gatekeeping obsession is
that you can never descent from our
viewpoint and if you do you have to be
crushed i i just want to say what little
credibility taylor lorenz may have had
went out the window when she accused
youtubers of being radicalized for
commenting on pop culture yeah like what
do you
i'm sorry but like commenting on pop
culture is the most generic
normal
american thing that it's like tmz it's
it's it's gossip magazines people being
like johnny depp and amber heard movie
stars let me give you my opinions and
people being like well i think this
that's radicalization because i'm sorry
if you want to talk about like white
nationalists and stuff talk about
radicalization i'm listening but when
you claim that commenting on johnny depp
was radicalizing you have been
radicalized i'm just like a female a
female practicing attorney commenting on
a on a trial is radicalizing i mean it's
it's it is she she lost credibility a
long time ago but again usa today how
are they still certified taylor lorenz
how is she still employed or getting
contracts
can you imagine being one of these
veteran reporters of the washington post
you know you're there for 20 years
and you're just dreaming of that day
that you can be like woodward and
bernstein and you're going to get that
big story and you know over the past 10
years past eight years it's been really
kind of oh you know it's just getting
weird and then they hire this this high
paid you know millennial who just
writes garbage conflict of interest news
and nonsense and you're like that's it
that's the talent that's the big money
yeah how could you oh you've got to quit
and i well let me or you end up the
subject like the one reporter did to uh
being potentially uh doxed by his own
fellow workers for making a joke in the
sense of the personal attacks that just
escalated i mean what we're seeing i
mean you look at the white house
remember sternovich when he went there
and he was like look at all these are
all kids these are all 20 year olds they
have no clue about the real world oh
yeah yeah we had we had someone on the
show once um
who said that they weren't familiar with
joe biden's administration because they
were only a they were like a young
teenager
and i was like oh
so you that's why you voted for him i'm
36 i remember i remember what it was
like 10 years ago i remember what the
obama administration was doing in the
middle east so when joe biden comes
around i'm like none of that but you
were 12.
so you had no idea what happened but now
you're old enough to vote so you do well
you're seeing some of the old left
that's coming back up uh that's you know
with jimmy dore aaron monte glenn
greenwald that's actually resurfacing in
the pope bill maher in the post-trump
era now that they're past tds who are
just discovering oh wow joe biden's
really a warmonger he's actually been a
warmonger for 30 years but they're
rediscovering this bill mark corrupt
corporate hack for 30 years and finally
he's being exposed as such we had dennis
prager on the other day and he was
saying that he's not going to
you know fault bill maher for you know
for being a liberal but trying and
calling things out so you know give him
the space i think it's fair point bill
maher has called out a lot of the will
craziness and so as a media personality
i can respect that i just wish the guy
would read the news yeah yeah exactly he
comments on it without reading it and
that's just crazy a week after covington
happens he's still wrong about it and
i'm like and the audience is cheering
exactly thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you